[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où on va parler du sénat puisqu'il ya eu
des élections va parler de vidéo
protection ou de vidéo surveillance un
peu d'éducation de citoyenneté aussi et
pourant par les anciens de la joie ni
bonjour des éditeurs alors à un nouveau
livre par ericsson voilà un scénario
c'est un une traduction dans un tout à
fait français c'est un auteur d'une
heure mais c'est un pseudo puisqu'il est
il suppose joker est prof
voilà donc si si et c'est un très bon
roman qui se passe dans le nord devant
dans la france du côté de shell avec eux
voilà une bande d'une bonne une bande de
punks qui terrorise un peu la cité des
cadavres qui brûle dans un cimetière et
puis un trio de policiers tout à fait
intéressant et original et voilà c'est
une très belle enquête avec un fond
social vraiment intéressant important
une bonne bonne étude de moeurs
on est presque ya un côté sinon dans
l'étude de moeurs qu'elle est assez
génial un superbe couverture en plus
c'est des gens qui ont pas encore lu les
tripes à la corde quand on va au théâtre
mais le meilleur était formidable et
c'est vrai c'était fade montceau
bourgeot patrice professeur à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
oui public ancien mineur de l'université
et jean baptiste duquel bonjour
c'est triste cette même université avec
vous notamment du sénat ce qu'il faut
faire pour sauver le sénat ce qu'il faut
supprimer c'est une belle question
florence mercadé bonjour être ajoutés au
barreau de versailles et d'autres
invitations de jemmapes
c'est la vie ça faisait un petit moment
que je n'étais pas venu sur un objet
tout un cofondateur de la compagnie
black blanc beur alors dès ce vendredi
soir et il ya un spectacle à maurepas et
qui s'appelle à bout de souffle il fait
parler de ce qu'on appelle le jul y aura
tout à fait de mes trois noms comme on
vit trois juniors 3g n'y aura pas de
rapport avec eux sinon le titre parce
que le jour où mathieu raul le jeune
chorégraphe puisque c'est la première
pièce où il s'affirme comme tel m'a
parlé de ce titre jus du monde ça y est
c'est fait on fera pas mieux enfin pas
vu et puis après j'ai vu ce qu'il a fait
et ce que je dis c'est bon garde
voilà alors il a modifié le titre c'est
aboud à baudoin souffre mais je ne suis
pas sûre ce soit une astuce plus que ça
je crois que ça correspond vraiment à
donc une très belle pièce une seconde
pièce qui était un peu pièce écoles
voulait compris les juniors c'est un
processus heures de spectacle école de
voilà voilà donc qu'ils avaient déjà
réalisé une pièce ap le paradoxe qui a
pas mal tourné est déjà chez en un
véritable niveau professionnel alors
niveau professionnel c'est quoi c'est
des gens bien sûr qu'ils maîtrisent les
techniques mais qui ont ce petit truc en
plus qui ont fait des artistes déjà à
savoir une capacité une incarnation
d'une capacité de 2,2 d'être autre chose
que ce qu'ils apparaissent et parfois
d'acquérir une justesse de jeu et
d'expression que n'ont pas forcément
tous les gens qui maîtrisent toutes ces
techniques et là c'est quelque chose qui
se confirme très nettement danser dans
cette pièce sur le thème donc de de
l'immigration il ya encore un poncif le
titre
trop connu le thème un poncif et
pourtant la pièce dans la vie faut venir
voir aucun propos de jeu avec les mots
âme à bout de souffle
si vous prenez un gps etc entre nicolas
à bout dans dans 50 ans et comme le
prenons gps ni prendre la drs nicolas
about
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est mignon si alors le prochain
spectacle de bonnement au beurre c'est
pour l'année prochaine voilà c'est vivre
debout
alors non non non c'est dû au sol majeur
pardon voilà tout à fait c'est une pièce
que va réaliser donc a commencé notre
chorégraphe qui a co fondé la compagnie
avec moi vaut absolument que sync ou
d'un et ça fait déjà l'objet de quinze
minutes qui ont été élaborées sur un duo
s'appelle duo en sol majeur sachant que
c'est un traitement de la stylistique de
la breakdance donc le sol c'est aussi
traitement du sol mais c'est aussi le
traitement du centre il ya quinze
minutes qui existent nous avons présenté
le 29 avril dernier dans une nuit de la
danse au centre n'en a pas et la
réaction du public ce que j'ai vu moi
personnellement nous encourage à
poursuivre donc ça devrait devenir une
pièce d'une heure et qui est vraiment un
traitement oui c'est ça sur sur la
stylistique de la présidence à la fois
très abstraite et en même temps je crois
qu'elle arrive à une sorte de simplicité
directement touchante qui fait que
vraiment les très excité à poursuivre ce
projet pour ce projet nous allons être
soutenu nous sommes en tractations avec
la scène conventionnée l'odyssée de
périgueux vous savez qui fait le fait ni
moss les deux centres chorégraphiques
nationaux dédiés à la aux expressions de
hip hop à savoir le ccn de créteil et le
ccn de la rochelle et nous aurons sans
doute la possibilité de faire une
première parisienne à la maison des
métallos donc la faire comment ça
s'était lié aux 35 ans va pas loin de 30
ans et 34 le 15 et 16 septembre dernier
pour la partie visée
puisque comme vous le savez c'est un
processus et initier cinq ans avant mais
voilà oui donc on arrive sur une
quarantaine d'années effectivement un
certain nombre de unes une belle
expérience pratique
alors on parlait tout à l'heure de vivre
debout et oui c'est un autre projet qui
s'appelle prises en compte
voilà donc je vous en parle parce
qu'elles vivent quelque chose qui est en
train de le devenir du sable et blade
mauvaise voie non pas tout seul et puis
de 2,2 d'autre chose parce que ça c'est
aussi un jeu pas me disais on va parler
de citoyenneté et de réappropriation du
du territoire est ce que c'est ce que
vous faites avec un hymne à sophie
marceau notamment mais on va en parler
un petit peu tout à l'heure on va au var
balayé un petit peu l'actualité de ces
derniers jours alors on va commencer par
les les élections sénatoriales
peut-être d'abord un commentaire général
victoire de la droite
échec de macron comment gérer voilà on
l'a utilisé comme ça ce que faire autre
chose enfin c'est ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire beaucoup mieux et nous donner ne
pouvait pas en être autrement si ce
thème du vin sur donc je n'ai absolument
rien d'étonnant il ya que les climats
chrono fob
avaient été ré contrôle d'accès et une
une défaite de mâcon je prenne des fêtes
c'est le mode électoral voilà je viens
dans trois ans sera éventuellement une
défaite oui s'il s'est dit il faut
rappeler comment comment se passent les
des élections ce qu'on appelle des
grands électeurs c'est à dire des gens
qui sont déjà conseillers municipaux
conseillers généraux donc il faut avoir
un ancrage dans le territoire pour avoir
des sénateurs ce qu'ont les partis
traditionnels ce conte - les nouveaux
partis évidemment on espère que tous ces
grands électeurs ont été élus à l'époque
où macron n'était même pas candidat à la
présidence était encore ministre ou
peut-être même pas enfin donc voilà
c'est pas du tout donc il n'y avait pas
de parti républicain en marche enfin ce
parti n'existe l'estadio ont été votés
pendant le cours de l'été donc y avait
pas de partis pas d'ancrage donc c'est
je pense que c'est aux grands électeurs
ont protégé lors de parties le corps
électoral sénatorial est composée à plus
de 95% de conseillers municipaux et de
délégués des communes donc le si vous
les lecteurs qui ont été élus à
bretelles et autres élections en 2014
et rien que le au fond ce qui fait
l'élection sénatoriale c'est l'élection
municipale ils en sont les élections
municipales d'abord et donc le le la
composition du sénat est une
photographie en différé de se laisser
passer aux élections municipales
précédentes et les élections municipales
avait vu la victoire des républicains
la droite et les élections sénatoriales
voit aussi rien que de très normal comme
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui sauve le psg
serait exactement sinon psa aurait - 12
10 - 12 sénateurs alors pas partout dans
les yvelines par exemple il ya 5 sur les
6 les sénateurs 5 sénateurs l air et un
sénateur de la république en mars quand
même le ps n'a même plus de sénateur
dans les yvelines est alors à la rue
juste ça comment elle explique c'est
parce que il ya quand même qu'ils ont
quand même d'aider des élus ils ont
quand même oui mais lorsque c'est aussi
pour cela que enfin le président de la
république espérait aussi faire un peu
mieux c'est à dire les les candidats aux
élections sénatoriales font leur travail
ils font une campagne électorale
lorsque j'étais conseiller municipal
enfin pendant six ans d'une petite
commune le temps de m'apercevoir que la
vie politique n'était pas du tout fait
pour moi ou l'averse je ne vais pas fait
du tout pour la vie pour l'été une
campagne une campagne très particulière
il ya un entre soi qui est assez assez
étonnant à vivre et savourer entre
grands électeurs avec des candidats qui
viennent vous voir à titre presque
personnelle qui viennent vous démarchez
pour avoir votre robe l'académie
française rem et et lorsque lorsqu'on se
réunit pour voter alors le vois tu es a
ceci de particulier qu'il est
obligatoire pour les grand series à 700
euros d'amendé et donc lorsque c'est
normal lorsque les grands électeurs se
réunissent pour voter ça se fait alors
je pense ça se fait toujours au palais
des congrès à versailles un dimanche
matin
vous allez candidats qui sont là et qui
viennent saluer enfin tout le monde plus
ou moins ce que l'on veut dans le même
endroit absolument au même endroit en
général à la préfecture du chef louis ou
alors dans un lieu qui se situe en
général sur
au chef-lieu du département d'état et
donc les communes affrète des débuts se
dit et donc c'est vraiment une ambiance
très particulière c'est un entre soi qui
alors que j'allais dire un côté malsain
mais peut-être pas mais face et c'est un
autre soit presque république de
notabilité c'est très iiième reich est
un des représentants les plus connus des
associés puisqu'on a pourrait appeler
l'association culturelle enfin le est ce
que ça serait presque par exemple si on
demandait aux représentants des
associations voter aux sénatoriales
pensais que ça serait une bonne chose
difficile de répondre à une question
pareille parce que déjà il faut
qualifier quel type de récréation à la
société vu que là il ya à boire et à
manger une diversité absolument
incroyable mais il ya en gros deux types
d'associations il ya des associations
qui sont dans des fonctionnalités
locales qui font juste de l'offre de
service et avec beaucoup de bénévoles et
puis la gestion comme les associations
artistiques qui ont choisi le meilleur
statut c'est à dire le sassi de statut
d'associé au pouvoir l'autre sont des
professionnels oui alors si on se base
nous c'est-à-dire associations de
professionnels
quel sens ça qu'on n'ait plus à dire sur
le le sénat que d'autres formes de la
représentation je ne sais pas répondre à
ça sur le principe général d'une forme
d'expression des populations à travers
la vie associative et c'est joli comme
ça à dire mais c'est toujours le
problème de poster
auxerre le vote et quelle est la valeur
de la représentation existantes on va
par fabriquer les représentations ont ré
abordera peut-être s'assure animateur a
dit massa c'est justement cette question
qui se pose est comment a installé une
forme de présence active de capacité
d'agir des habitants à travers le réseau
associatif sans tronquées ou sans
revendiquer de la représentant sahraoui
s'est enfin je pense que c'est la
question à larmor comment par exemple on
va pouvoir je préfère parler de ça parce
que leur est pas et c'est un peu une
question
ceci dit patrice une petite observation
c'est que en irlande la chambre ou
autres représentent la société civile
donc c'est vrai que le modèle sata donne
une légitimité d'un conte horrifique ce
qu'il puisse y avoir non non c'était pas
une ola mais c'est répondre comme ça sur
la question n'était pas aussi alors
justement il ya un gros débat qui est
fatigué qui est très ancien dont bien
maurice duverger j'ai de belles
références modèles afin qu'ils étaient
très favorables à la suppression du
sénat c'était dans les années 60-70 st
le grand constitutionnaliste et grand
spécialiste de de windows rock aussi j
ja bell et le débat alors il ya eu le
référendum de 69 ou de gaulle avait su
proposer la suppression du sénat
le référendum a été repoussée mais c'est
une question qui revient de temps en
temps alors est ce qu'il faut ou non
supprimer le sénat
je propose un duel entre
jean baptiste d'uccle et stéphane minson
et puis après tout le monde intervient
jean baptiste à votre avis pourquoi
faudrait-il supprimer le cédrat ou non
modifiés alors déjà je note que la
question se pose uniquement pour la
chambre haute et pas pour la chambre où
seulement après que l'on se pose pas la
question de la suppression alors il ya
plusieurs arguments qui peuvent être
avancées il ya d'abord un argument
historique c'est que c'est vrai que le
sénat n'a pas toujours existé dans notre
histoire constitutionnelle l'a pas
existe en 191 il a existé en 1848 et le
sénat toujours été une assemblée très
conservatrice elle était seul at-il
ancien sans mode de désignation très
très fidèle aux empereurs au roi sous la
restauration et elle a encore été très
fidèles à la monarchie sous la troisième
république puisque le sénat était à
majorité donc monarchistes et c'est même
alliés d'une certaine manière avec le
président de la république de l'époque
mcmahon lorsqu'il a voulu prononcer la
dissolution de la chambre des députés
alors même que les français avaient
donné leur confiance aux républicains et
elle a pu de ce point de vue là être
considérée comme une assemblée
antidémocratique et c'est vrai que c'est
un petit peu resté il ya un petit peu
cette idée suivant laquelle la chambre
ou autre est un petit peu un peu moins
comment dirais-je liés au suffrage
universel direct
et c'est encore le cas sous la vème
république puisque elle n'a pas la même
légitimité que l'assemblée nationale
universel indirect suffrage universel
indirect ont parlé des grands électeurs
tout à l'heure et c'est d'ailleurs un
des éléments qui me fait dire que le
sénat pourrait être supprimée dans la
mesure où il a une légitimité discutable
que représente le sénat selon la
constitution il assure la représentation
des collectivités territoriales et donc
ils représentent des territoires et en
termes de légitimité démocratique on
peut arriver à des situations où un
sénateur suivant qu'on est dans la
creuse dans le var va représenter 65 me
ou 2,71 me les lecteurs un autre
argument qui plutôt un argument
politique qui est liée au fait que le
sénat et que l'alternance politique est
un signe de vitalité démocratique et le
sénat toujours été à droite si ce n'est
deux entre 2 millions et demi il est de
droite puisque il
ils assurent comme le disait tout à
l'heure stéphane essentiellement il
représente essentiellement les
conseillers municipaux et donc les
petites communes et les petites
territoires qui sont sur représentés de
sorte que représente ce qui fait dire
que le scénario quand même une assemblée
qui marquait d'un point de vue politique
et l'alternance n'est pas très forte
et puis il me semble que c'est un
argument plutôt institutionnel que le
sénat ne et bien participent autant
longue qui peut être vu comme un
avantage mais qui de mon point de vue
est un inconvénient
dès lors que le processus législatif est
extrêmement long extrêmement pénible et
que nous vivions dans des sociétés où il
faut absolument de la vitesse de la
rapidité de la célérité et je pense en
particulier au domaine du numérique pour
lesquels à chaque fois qu'une loi est
votée elle est quasiment désuète
entre temps les révolutions
technologiques le mandat était réduit
c'était devant autrefois ces six ans
maintenant
ouais mais bon stéphane mans sont alors
vous êtes plutôt pour le maintien
d'une deuxième chambre oui patrice telle
qu'elle est ça sent la fusionner par
exemple parce que parfois on dirait la
fusionner avec le conseil économique et
social et environnemental
oui mais non vous êtes pour le maintien
oui à un duel amical un thread il est
normalement dévolu foutu ici on passe
ici pour pour pour reprendre les
arguments que jean baptiste que
j'entends et que j'écoute je pense
qu'une institution doit jamais être
prisonnière de son passé de son histoire
c'est vrai que cela pas brillé par son
caractère très progressiste le recours
d'un triste war constitutionnel mais si
c'est cela viendra peut-être un jour
le sénat a toujours été à droite
mise à part la parenthèse de trois ans
que vous évoquiez mais enfin on sait
jamais ce qui peut se passer
le zèle l'alchimie électorale est
tellement inexplicable que voilà je
crois que tout est ouvert de ce point de
vue là sur le mode de désignation c'est
souvent un procès qu'on fait au sénat en
dix ans et suffrage universel indirect
donc c'est moins démocratique que le
suffrage universel direct et qui
lui-même engage dans une démocratie de
représentation qui serait moins
démocratique que la démocratie directe
bon ça je trouve tout cela extrêmement
discutable le maire est élu au suffrage
universel indirect puisque ils élus du
conseil municipal qui pensent à
supprimer le maire de ce seul point de
vue il semble même pas la légitimité
parce qu'il n'est pas élu directement
par les électeurs
d'ailleurs des hypothèses dans
lesquelles le maire n'est pas la tête de
liste
2 pour laquelle les gens ont voté oui
c'est ça c'est déjà fait bon et ça c'est
ça se voit c'est rare mais ça a l'air
bon moi moi la raison majeure qui me me
pousse plutôt à soutenir l'existence du
sénat c'est sa dualité avec l'assemblée
nationale décidément c'est pas de
considérer le sénat tout seul parce
qu'il n'est pas tout seul justement il
il côtoie l'assemblée nationale pour
l'examen des lois vous pour l'examen des
textes pour le contrôle qu'il peut
exercer sur gouvernement alors il n'a
pas les mêmes pouvoirs constitutionnels
que l'assemblée et le la constitution
tient compte justement du fait que le
sénat n'est pas l'émanation directe du
corps électoral n'en est qu'une
émanation indirects mais le sénat vient
alors pondéré vient porter une tonalité
un peu différente de celle qui est porté
par l'assemblée nationale
un rythme différent moi j'entends bien
que il faut accélérer que la vitesse
c'est bien que d'aller plus vite c'est
mieux mais je doute quand même que ça a
quelque chose de bon s'est
traditionnellement la seule chose qui
s'oppose au fond au pouvoir exécutif
et quel qu'il soit vous aurez vous le
répète si cassy testé fin mai avec au
moins l'efficacité du débat au moins
l'efficacité de la publicité du débat de
porter sur la place publique un certain
nombre de débats qui sont d'ailleurs
extrêmement bien conduit nous en
parlions tout à l'heure alors pas plus
ce cas là je ne dis pas que les
sénateurs ne travaille pas ni que les
députés ne travaille pas mais on sait
l'intérêt travail est belle les
sénateurs travaillent des contres
contrairement à une idée reçue il est le
scot le soleil la moyenne d'âge du sénat
est plus jeune que ça le drame elle
l'était c'est simplement d'échanger avec
les dernières s'échangent régulièrement
mais il y avait d'ailleurs fait ce
n'était pas si vieux que ça il y avait
d'ailleurs me semble-t-il plus de femmes
au sénat législature qu'à l'assemblée
mais justement cette cette arythmie
entre les deux chambres parlementaires
mois m'intéresse beaucoup
cette dualité et puis le sénat enfin oui
c'est joli c'est beaucoup il faut aller
simple trait chaves et les ordres les
hommes et la démocratie un coup alors où
elle assume on n'assume pas cette
suppression du nombre d'élus alors c'est
à la mode et ses ondes et libérera mieux
paraît-il si on est beaucoup moins salée
ils sont pas ils sont rarement toussaint
dans l'hémicycle et en commission je moi
j'aime pas cet argument qui dit on a
trop d'élus etc
il ya dans les promesses des menus le
maquereau le se ferait notamment
développé bien il ya très peu d'élus
lozari son qui sont payés il ya un
argument que je trouve vraiment curieux
et presque vraiment anti démocratique de
la part de notre avis c'est à dire que
c'est de dire oui le sénat et de droite
comme si c'était une tare une semaine
mais c'est incroyable j'ai dit tantôt
comme un vrai il faut le supprimer ce
que cette droite est et de la rue des
années c'est toi c'est pas c'est un
constat
il ya une surreprésentation ça vous
pouvez pas le nier ddd de la sphère
rural sur la sphère des lauriers des
villes et qui ne correspond peut-être
pas à la sociologie actuelle du pays
voilà partis
vous faites partie des gens qui veulent
changer le peuple alors le peuple vote
pas bien au sénat votre nom c'est la
présentation d'un event c'est ce que
disait très justement stéphane veut dire
vrai les gens pas été élu on n'a pas
tiré leurs noms dans un chapeau donc
critiquer ce monde rural et puis et puis
c'est toujours méprisé maurice duverger
revient parmi nous hahaha
mais peut être d'ailleurs pour la
suppression du sénat et vous enfin mois
on parlait du sénat tel qu'il est
constitué de vivre tout à fait y avoir
une autre forme de sénart on peut y
avoir une forme
j'attendais d'ailleurs est-ce que donc
stéphane face à promotion du bicamérisme
égalitaire à l'italienne où on a deux
chambres qui ont la même légitimité avec
les mêmes pouvoirs avec la possibilité
d'en renverser le gouvernement et
caetera et on sent bien que ce schéma
n'a pas été adoptée justement parce
qu'on craint les conséquences néfastes
en termes de rapidité dans le processus
d'élaboration de la loi donc sur ce
sujet juste un petit mot en travers de
tout ce qui vient des dix mois la notion
d'un espace où on a plus de temps où on
vient de plus loin dans le temps et
quelque chose à malines extrêmement
important à préserver et elles sont
rentrées sur toute la pensée de virilio
on va trop vite ont fait 3 8 extrême
mais en y pensant quand même un petit
peu dans ce que vous avez dit
effectivement on peut saisir une
intention mais il ne l'a pas dit
patty dire aussi commencé moi j'aurais
dit la même chose si ça avait été la
gauche et d'un constat peut-être pas
mais parker alors ses restaurants moi je
me suis bien dans le genre du canard
enchaîné qui s'appelait les fromages de
la république voudrait alors moi c'est
de ce côté là c'est à dire du côté de
l'objectivité des moyens qui sont
dévolues à ces espaces mais sur le
principe d'un espace comme je détale
heure où la chronicité où la qualité des
et savoir de l'expérience et remises en
dise à disposition de ceux qui doit
aller vite parce qu'ils doivent vite
alors là je dirais que voilà je pense
que c'est un argument qui va dans le
sens de sans doute le réformer sans
doute là mincir mais peut-être pas le
supprimer
très vite alors des élections c'est
naturel vont de t'avoir évidemment des
conséquences sur le territoire puisque
parmi les les nouveaux sénateurs il y a
le maire de montigny et ne vous retenez
mais c'est l'audi président de saint
quentin en yvelines qui est un des
nouveaux sénateurs over the de voir un
peu son portrait et puis on parle
peut-être appelle des conséquences sur
le territoire a obtenu le seul michel
laugier 33 voix les images ont presque
13 ans jour pour jour ce 11 octobre 2004
à michel laugier voit son parcours
politique
concrètement débuté il devient alors le
maire de montigny le bretonneux à l'âge
de 46 ans
[Applaudissements]
ému et tendrement ému parce que toute la
soirée j'ai pensé un homme j'ai pensé à
nicolas bour celui que je viens de
remplacer lui qui a siégé à la tête de
ce conseil municipal pendant 27 ans et
demi écoutez ça fait un drôle d'effet de
se retrouver dans son fauteuil un
fauteuil de maire que le journaliste de
formation aura donc occupé pendant 13
ans et qui l'aura vu progressivement
grandir dans la cour politique
yvelinoise réélu maire en 2008 et 2014
michel laugier devient la même année
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sentiment de fierté
sont ils ont aussi de vivre une étape
importante puisque c'est historique que
président de droite préside aux
destinées aujourd'hui de la communauté
d'agglomération et son histoire
politique michel laugier continue de
l'écrire en 2015 candidat de la droite
pour les élections départementale sur le
canton de montigny le bretonneux il
réussir à conquérir un territoire
réservé à la gauche depuis 1994
lorsqu'on gagne un canton pour lequel on
est challenger
elles s'appellent et se fait plaisir en
plus le gagner d'une si belle façon je
crois qu'il est grand de satisfaction
élu sénateur michel logis et siègera
désormais dans une chambre connu pour
être plus ouverte au compromis politique
une caractéristique qui devrait lui
correspondre lui le parlementaire de
droite qui n'a jamais été encarté niais
l'ump ni aux républicains évidemment ça
va ouvrir une nouvelle élection alors à
l'homme une grille de de montigny est
évidemment à la présence de la
communauté
c'est un peu tôt pour commenter ce qui
va se passer
non
[Musique]
on a enfoncé à peu près
comment ça pouvait se passer a priori
c'est évidemment la droite garde la
majorité dans le noter à moins qu'il y
ait des divisions de ce qui est toujours
possible qu'on verra vision voulait rien
dire là-dessus non non non la prochaine
fois un peu trop tôt ou a posteriori
pour faire un commentaire sur
possibilité oui
donc laissons faire je me trompe
peut-être un nouveau rapide oui je pense
qu'ils gagnent en prestige mais hyper en
pouvoir je crois qu'on a tous en mer que
si cette heure probablement
certainement même jeu sénateurs alors
même si sénateurs en est un parmi à
combien à 100 de 363 114-114 l'ordre et
on a beaucoup moins de pouvoir puisque
en validant une majorité extra-large en
plus le sénat
343 soit 50,3 beaucoup moins de pouvoir
que qu'est l'assemblée nationale et on
sent quand un maire énormément de
pouvoir il peut changer vraiment le clos
maire le président le mieux d'une
agglomération aussi c'est ce que disent
toujours derrière les lycées qui étaient
contents du maire on voit les
conséquences de ses décisions contourner
et du national on les voit beaucoup
moins je suppose enfin elles sont plus
longues
si on est député on les voit quand même
sénateur on ne veut pas parce que quoi
qu'il dessine c'est l'assemblée qu'elle
dernier le ton est plus long le temps a
autant d'applications dans l'application
quand vous construisez c'est pas une
école voilà le construite et la période
de fait majoritaire le l'assemblée
nationale en faisant qu'à part du sénat
quand même une chambre d'enregistrement
pour l'essentiel des décisions qui ont
été prises par le gouvernement
c'est en cela aussi que je dis pas
semblé l'assemblée nationale en
particulier non le sénat en faisant cas
à part puisque l'international peut
surmonter une décision contraire du
sénat il y aura alors il ya une autre
conséquence qui est assez intéressante
aussi on leur parlait justement de la
réduction par exemple du nombre de
députés de sénateurs
ça demande une révision
constitutionnelle pour avoir une
révision constitutionnelle il faudrait
que la majorité au congrès c'est-à-dire
l'assemblée le sénat l'a a priori le
président la république et le mans n'ont
pas non mais enfin ils n'ont pas en soi
après ça peut se négocier ça se négocie
toujours jusqu'au jusqu'à la dernière
minute les coups de téléphone etc
mais cela dit le président république à
une autre solution c'est la solution du
peuple de recourir au peuple si si les
engrais en même temps ça peut être très
pratique aussi parce que il annonce des
choses puis après dubawi désolé je vais
annoncer je vais une bonne idée mais
c'est pas possible on mettra plus tard
voilà comme ça tout le monde est content
aider les gens qui volent un peu moins
de députés de willy l'a proposé
mitterrand avait très bien joué là
dessus
la crise de l'école mais c'est en
faisant référendum et an 10 au dessus
dab et c'est pas possible de le faire
puisque marie donc donc ça s'est
toujours très bien
j'ai des jours ça va moins ça va il
paraît que vous parlez beaucoup de
politiques
mais oui on m'a envoyé des tentes en
train de parler du sénat vous avez vous
aurez peut être sénateur d'ailleurs de
bretagne
non je suis beaucoup trop vieux c'est
vrai que ça s'est rajeuni un peu le sait
pas comment ça va
oui puis surtout ça je trouve que ça guy
qui très vite
qu'est ce que vous faites ça y est la
non non je suis venu je vous expliquerai
tout à l'heure mais peut-être peut-être
pas devant tout le monde n'en gagnent
mais si on est viré de beaucoup plus
haut et fort sa demande des explications
pour qui travaillez vous à nous oui au
pour tout nouveau vus particulièrement
moi partir pour qui ce travail
oui actuellement oui actuellement il ya
toute une étude qui est en cours sur
vous ah non pas seulement parce que nos
cerveaux surtout ceux qui effectivement
convoyeur redistribue les cartes en
matière de d'importance sur le plan
politique
en gros c'est ça et donc on voit bien
que certains trouvent qu'ils sont en
train de perdre la main donc ça suscite
veuille pas malde enquête et de temps en
temps ils prennent des vieux barbon
comme moi par exemple remerciait le
comprendre pourquoi tout d'un coup
quelqu'un marche plus de mieux qu'un
autre
ah ah
intéressant au cerveau ou alors pour
savoir aussi mais qu'il paye
ah oui mais vous trouvez pas ça
scandaleux effectivement qu'on puisse
poser la question de savoir qui paye est
oui mais pas ce que ça veut dire quoi
qu'on soutient une aire de soupçon
généralisé où on pense que des gens sont
payés chez pas parler d'elle depuis
toujours depuis toujours et l'ovi parler
depuis toujours c'est bien connu quand
même depuis toujours davantage des
comptes y avait très peu de chaînes
c'était le propriétaire de la chaîne
on va prendre quelque chose de récent
comme bolloré on voit bien que bolloré
et qui a les moyens de doctes orienter
la solution de sa chaîne n'est d'accord
mais avant c'était plutôt l'état et
aujourd'hui c'est un peu le bordel sa
part de partout même dans le service mu
est basse et surtout se dit même dans le
service public mais surtout il ya plein
d'autres chaînes comme vous ici oui
c'est ça qui est embêtant parce que
parce qu'en fait vous serez les dossiers
les pattes de des chaînes publiques
donc c'est vrai elles deviennent
cul-de-jatte rendez compte que c'est une
chaîne cul-de-jatte imaginait là un
petit saladier
cette chaîne est une chaîne privée mais
un peu mais avait aussi financé par un
peu de public
c'est vrai mais c'est pas un argument de
défense de toute façon plus vous avez de
monde et plus vous avez public et oui
plus apte financier ses devanciers
absolument vrai deuxièmement mine de
rien on les fait payer aussi des
spectateurs
oui je sais pas trop comment ici mais
beaucoup de chaînes à bas à travers les
travers la publicité à travers sept
consommateurs après que c'est le
consommateur qui finance à feu doux est
ce que vous sentez lire ici tout à fait
choisissez vos partenaires aujourd'hui
par exemple et si oui alors d'abord
c'est une émission qui fait avec d'aider
des gens qui ne sont pas des
journalistes
je voulais présenter comme ça vous alors
jean charles lajoie n'y est éditeur
stéphanois sur le professeur de
propublica diversité jean baptiste
duclair et maître de conférences à
l'université
selon ce père cadette avocate au barreau
de versailles est gentil aimable c'est
le fondateur de la compagnie black blanc
beur qui est le le le
on veut pas dire le nom c'est enfin le
premier grand groupe de hip hop voilà le
fondateur du hip hop en france en gros
et je vous êtes contents de notre panel
de trouver kiyal que ce qui les
représentent à peu près qu'il est
représentatif
absolument pas alors merci il faut
regretter de ne pas être représenté
non ici on s'y enfonce dans la
représentativité ou dit faut des quotas
moi je trouve alors que là vous faites
vraiment des beauvais ses missions moi
je préfère des gens qui savent parler et
qui en est qui ont quelque chose à dire
que quelqu'un parce que il est ceci
parce qu'il est cela qu on a vite mais
je vais prendre un exemple de cet état
d'un temps les missions qu'on me donne
et c'est essayer de comprendre pourquoi
plus personne ne veut donner la parole
aux communistes la langue mais qui
essayait au début on a des habitants
oui il est parti pas de pénis j'ai
écouté
honnêtement je ne sais pas ce que votent
oui désolé les autres il ya des zones
autorisées pour sur une frite au plus
tôt gildas a raison parce que
effectivement pas de lepéniste y en a
pas au tour de na pas là mais j'appuie
de merdes v n'ont plus que deux
mais aussi un ami de françois peillon
vers où justement il aimait rhdp a beau
mais là encore il est une ville à une
demi-douzaine de casquettes
j'ai fait une enquête récemment ça je ne
fais plus que ça bah oui parce que je ne
veux surtout pas les chaînes de
télévision devenue beaucoup trop
dangereux à ce poids là non plus la
soirée certaines âge on vous paie plus
la voudrait plus vous veillez très bien
non mais c'est vrai que ça a beaucoup
changé justement josé trajet je le
regarde la télévision
ils font venir parce que je ne regarde
jamais la télévision alors qu'en jamais
on la regarde jamais quand on l'a fait
mais met à nous nous nous mêmes même la
télévision actuelle n'a plus jamais vous
les regardez vous des grandes chaînes
non non alors qu'est ce que vous
regardez alors je regarde peu la télé
n'est dangereux non cela pratiquement
pas là donc vous lisez les journaux je
lis les journaux ça m'arrive je suis un
peu comme moi c'est un peu comme je suis
très jeune homme a donc j'ai un peu sur
les ordinateurs sur les deux réseaux
d'écrans comme beaucoup de gens non je
vais vous donner une question surgit las
mais peut-être que ça m'a échappé et et
vous qui vous a payé ou commandités pour
faire baisser tout de cette image je
voulais pas dit non non non non mais
voilà ça passait bien qu'il m'a fait
confiance et je trouve ça tout à fait
normal qu alors et à propos de ça te
raconter cette histoire au tout début de
l'émission il ya un membre du csa qui
s'appelle nicolas vous si vous mettez le
gps ici vous savez qu'à une rue nicolas
avoue et le gps10 prendre la rue nicolas
about et donc on va pas aller plus loin
comme elle fois vous vous amusez
beaucoup or je voulais c'est si vous
voulez parler de la vidéo surveillance
inoni
vous parlez de rien du tout je suis
venue de ce uniquement pour dire bonjour
je voyais jouer n'importe quoi est ce
que tu me gueule d'enquêteurs non je
suis pour sa méthode est quand même dit
il est quand même passé de l'autre côté
j'ai l'âge d'abord bascule non non je
suis toujours admiratif ne voulais pas
rester avec nous si si c'est bien ou pas
non sérieusement je suis le patron il
aurait quand même pu justifier c'est lui
qui m'a donné la mission s'est plaint
donc on aurait pu lui demander pourquoi
pour une fois n'aurait plus dû passer de
lui poser des questions à lui parce que
moi ça m'étonne quand même je suis donc
venu pour vous dire bonjour et peu c'est
fait
avant de rêver je vous laisse travailler
alors à moi que vous vouliez on est en
train de dépasser
vous savez que dans les yvelines va être
généralisé pour appels vidéo protection
est paraît-il une vidéo protection
intelligente geste et hier karl olive
qui est un conseiller général raconté ce
qui va se passer puis on en parle après
investissement de 13 millions dans les
116 collèges du département dans les
casernes de pompiers notamment tout
simplement pour créer une plate forme
mutualisée d' images de vidéo protection
dans un espèce de maillage de logiciels
robotisée qui fait que des cures un
moule devant un mouvement de foule dans
tous ces endroits se sera directement
opérationnels dans ce centre de
supervision urbain
efficacité réactivité aujourd'hui dans
le pays en état d'urgence ce qui est
nécessaire évidemment c'est la
réactivité par rapport à des incidents
de plus ou moins grande importance
alors ce serait des caméras paraît-il
intelligente
ces intelligences artificielles qui
arrive et elle a ajouté phil b je suis
contente plus d'entrées mais là où il ya
des caméras évidemment ce qu'on est
sensé je vous rappelle quand audrey à
votre place on est censé savoir tout
mais je veux nous avons écouté tout est
filmé dans les lieux où il ya des
caméras et des lieux seront de plus en
plus nombreux personne ne regarde les
images mais la caméra réagi contient un
bruit suspect une image suspecte elle
lance un appel
et là les gens peuvent élections qui
surveille ils peuvent venir intervenir
savoir où se passe quelque chose
d'obscène à peine acquis bahia il ya un
mur de bip qui fait que les gens qui ne
qui sera coté vont voir qu'est ce qui se
passe par exemple s'il ya un bruit de
bris de glace par exemple si un coup de
feu mais plutôt bien ça non alors vous
êtes pour vous êtes plutôt qu'aux autres
je suis donc on commence par jean
charles lajoie dit non je vois pas du
tout de problème alors une caméra placée
est intelligente c'est mieux
on est en train de partout d'essayer de
faire des économies dans toutes les
municipalités dont les dotations étaient
baissées etc
c'est pas des gens qui passent leur
temps toute la journée regarder des
images qui ont souvent peu d'intérêt
tant mieux et s'ils sont alertés
uniquement quelque chose qui se
déclenchent après faut savoir qui a dit
ce qu'ils étaient
grave ou pas grave pour que les caméras
se déclenche c'est un débat sûrement
très technique d'informaticiens mais ici
à une altercation un accident un casse
dans une boutique une jeune femme qui a
agressé une petite j'ai qui se fait
tirer son sac ce tout ça très bien qu'on
puisse le voir éventuellement après
arrêter le tout après le coupable a bien
sûr ça on va pas commencer alors je ne
me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit on va pas commencer à arrêter les
gens avant qu'ils aient commis un délit
ce serait quand même monstrueux c'est
donc moi je la suive tour le serait pas
mal non non non non la prévention non
non non les uns la presse c'est pas ça
la prévention et ça c'est pas dans la
rue brancion sinon c'est empêcher des
violences mais à regarder mais là ces
caméras de ce que je comprends personne
ne regarde les images il ya un bip qui
se déclenche mais qui prévient qui
comment je ne sais pas quoi la police
municipale non ces abris sont d'accord
bon donc on n'est plus dans on n'est pas
dans de la prévention on est peut-être
dans la dissuasion qui les gens savent
qu'il ya des caméras cet endroit là ils
vont peut-être pas aller à cet endroit
là pour tirer le sac de la petite
vieille par exemple mais on n'est plus
et puis ça va plus servir à
éventuellement à de l'élucidation sur
des sur des affaires se met cela étant
je pense que démarrer avec des caméras
comme ça que l'on mettrait partout moi
j'ai pas très envie quand je sors de
chez moi d'être filmé on est déjà tracée
par les cartes bancaires par les
téléphones portables les tracés par tous
et bien parce que non mais non mais
c'est ça ben voilà on fait rien de
répréhensible à ce que parce que vous
êtes vous êtes à blanc et là on est en
train de rentrer avec en plus la réforme
qui est en train de se mettre en place
en ce moment et qui en discussion sur
les contrôles d'identité 20 km aux
alentours des gares des aéroports soit
67% de la population va pouvoir être
contrôlés n'importe quand n'importe
comment sans aucune faute aucune raison
donc là on est en train de dire on va
filmer tout le monde nous sans les
accords des gens enfin bon on filme tout
le monde on va pouvoir contrôler tout le
monde et ça moi j'ai pas envie d'une
société de cette nature là qui au
surplus
je suis un peu dubitatif sur le sur les
effets futurs grands teams général
videla
je pense que nous faisons un métier mais
même quand ça n'est pas notre métier
mais quand on se retrouve invité là et
aide a dit appeler d'anti cercle comme
vous aujourd'hui c'est la liberté qui
prime c'est donc l'indépendance derrière
donc tout ce qui est l'espionnage et est
condamnable vous rendez compte
apparemment vous n'acceptez de commencer
l'espionnage qu'on appelle le contrôle
dans un premier temps mais ça devient
extraordinairement dangereux bien sûr
donc c'était mieux pour faire quoi oui
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il faut jamais
mettre un doigt dans ceux ci
cet engrenage c'est une idée oui si vous
n'avez rien à vous reprocher ensuite les
îles et les images ne sont pas conservés
donc là c'est de conserver mais comme
dans un grand magasin comme dans une
banque etc tout en suivant un rythme
suivant leur établissement toutes les 24
titres en disant ça va être supprimé et
d'un mois ou deux mais bon les rênes du
sida sion a posteriori saluons mais un
coup toute façon ils vont conduire
espionnage pour vérifier que
l'espionnage bien s'essaie au boudin
noir mais c'est enfermement d'affaires
qui sont élucidés et des aidants quai
qui aboutissent grâce aux caméras enfin
vous dire je le trouve ça très bien fait
franchement quand on braque une banque
c'est très bien que des caméras dans les
banques
mais là je veux bien commun ne valent
rien n'est pas partout qui se met pas
facile dans les aura dans les collèges
dans les casernes de pompiers
dans les sites administratifs c'est très
peu dans un premier temps en tout cas
c'est un métier en perspectives
extraordinaires vous êtes quoi je suis
chef du stockage 12e j'ai ça me rappelle
à chaque fois l'histoire de 2,2 de la
télé on a découvert un jour que il
n'avait jamais réglé la façon dont deux
bus fonctionnaient quelque chose qui
était aux buttes-chaumont là haut et qui
stockaient tout ce qui s'était passé
alors tf qui d'ailleurs pas s'appeler à
l'ouverture à l'époque mais rtf tout
court d'ailleurs
eh bien personne ne s'était posé la
question de savoir comment c'est arrivé
et je me souviens y être allé parce que
j'avais un copain qui était et qui
travaillait qu'il n'était pas
journaliste mais qui avait été embauché
pour ça et qu'ils étaient trop bu de
chaumont elle est tout se faisait à la
main ce que vous portent des côtes et
donc il y avait aucune règle aucun
classement n'a été prévu jean-pierre il
y avait un stop dans un coin était
quelque chose qui n'arriveraient
évidemment jamais il y avait dix mètres
cubes et quant aux autres alors il y
avait le retard sur les autres des
autres qu'ils avaient été prises et
mises dans l'est dans les cases cela
aussi il n'y avait pas assez de monde
pour donner une suite puisqu'il arrivait
de la matière tous les jours celle de la
vidéosurveillance a d'ailleurs là lol
monde pour pouvoir les images mais là on
a circonstances et si je me dis ça c'est
parce que c'était pas du tout de la
surveillance c'est uniquement des
archives qui prennent des choses
importantes qui s'était passé comme
votre réunion aujourd'hui et non pas
pour rechercher ce jour on en a parlé
rien de le retrouver même avait joué
didier patrie c'est justement pour ça
que ces caméras sont censés être
intelligent pour pains mobiliser des
régiments entiers de surveillants devant
des écrans s'éviter un progrès
intelligent mais comment et quand même
où elle commence l'intelligence de la
caméra se fera pas et ça c'est le grand
débat nous deux une intelligence sur
l'intelligence et sur les riches en
images sur l'intelligence d'un mois je
vais vous parler commune et ça s'arrête
dès qu'un bon relationnel sens que les
animaux paramètres on peut paramétrer
correctement un truc aussi si vous
pensez qu'avec un viol c'est pas grave
et cuba auquel avait congestion b si on
pense qu'une agression mais charles
quelles sont ces arguments
après non s'ils ne souriez pas une
caricature de vous massive on peut
agresser des pompiers et il faut pas
être filmés que devient la liberté de la
presse quand déjà il ya plus de liberté
pour les individus alors ce qu'en la
circonstance le tri est fait avant
d'après ce que vous venez de dire je
sais pas qui est assez intelligent dans
les machines ou dans les paires de temps
ou dans les jambes mais on en parle
d'intelligence aurait vite et c'est des
caméras qui sottise tu vas te fasse
couiner des faits donc elles ont été
programmés
c'est le tc cutter objectif c'est le
bruit celle ayant éclaté un truc anvers
où la cam est entamée trois régiments
route
ah oui il ya quelque chose qui va
falloir quand même non ce qui est assez
ce qui est assez intéressant c'est quand
même le budget c'est comme 13 millions
d'euros dans un premier temps promis
dans un premier temps parce que là il ya
que quelques lieux qui sont équipés
c'est une décision du conseil général
donc ça ne peut être que dans des lieux
qui dépendent du conseil d'état
peut-être qu ensuite des mairies peuvent
être intéressés les maires pourront
mettre dans leur ville les particuliers
s qui peuvent être équipées s'il le
souhaite pour l'instant non mais ce type
de caméra ne peut pas viser non c'est ce
que dit la loi dans les faits c'est
avoir pas viser des logements ou des
entrées de logement etc
enfin les caméras de rue en tout cas
mais cela dit au delà des copropriétés
qui installe talent voilà donc vous êtes
souriez vous êtes filmés
maintenant c'est pour ça que tu serais
tout le temps métier on voit certaines
pancartes des pancartes à l'entrée de
certains villages vais marquer village
sous vidéosurveillance
non pas moi je passerai délégué david
salesse à l'inquiéter qui était une
société qui est bien qu'ils étaient tous
et vous ça vous a plu tout ça vous
rassure vous raconter une histoire vraie
ouais quand quand il ya eu la première
grande réforme de l'information à la
télévision
et elles sont arrivées des gens très
connus par ailleurs comme pierre
bellemare aimé bellemare était né de la
radio pour les radios il venait même de
la télé déjà il faisait des émissions
sur la justice sur la trois ou quatre
treuils des presque des savants j'ai
envie de dire par rapport au niveau de
la télé de l'époque donc bellemare ça
devient le patron qui constitue son
équipe de bric et de broc et on se
retrouve tous dans le bureau il faut
dire qu'avant on le considérait que le
les chaînes et est totalement sous la
coupe du pouvoir comme on a vu c'était
clair clair et c'était vrai qu'en
peyrefitte est campé refait devenez
projet présenté les modifications du 20
heures
non donc la nouvelle équipe comportait
quelques anciens mais surtout beaucoup
d'autres qui avaient été repérés dans
les radios à droite ou à gauche etc et
leur à partir de ce moment quand il a
voulu qu'on bellemare a voulu expliquer
il n'avait pas ouvert les deux tiers 2
de ces trucs du mobilier qu'il y avait
là et notamment ils croyaient qu'un truc
non ne contenait que les bouteilles
d'apéritif le coeur le revenu s'ils en
avaient besoin
il regarde dedans il y avait un micro
à partir de là on a ouvert tout ce qu'il
y avait dans son aileron
c'était la première fois à mon avis
qu'il était dans son bureau ils
l'avaient réouvert du tout on a ouvert
tout est bien comme c'était la première
fois aussi qu'il y avait un patron qui
ne venait pas de la maison qu'ils
avaient été pris à l'extérieur
il avait mis des immigrés ou par coup
mais la demi trop et les amis de telle
sorte que pour qu'il soit efficace il
les avait mis de telle sorte que
j'imagine des micros à l'époque s'il
était déjà quelque chose ils devaient se
dire mais ça va ça va pas prendre de son
comme il faut donc il était bien il y
avait déjà la porte de tous les petits
mots qu il y en avait absolument partout
et ça c'est que ça c'est facile c'est en
1970 mais le gag c'est là pourtant le
premier l'art inha bd tout d'un coup
mais c'est la première période d'emploi
de libéralisation de druide la première
fois ça n'a pas duré longtemps on a tous
été futur et avant la bid ou parce que
ça n'obéissait pas assez bien non plus
il faut bien reconnaître que les gens
comme bellemare et les autres étaient
pas plu du tout pour dirigeants ce type
à l'équipe il a échappé l'habitude de la
liberté une telle liberté que les
équipes leur échapper totalement à leurs
mains et mais en revanche ce qui a été
extrêmement drôle c'est que après avoir
fait le ménage avoir enlevé tous les
petits micros qui avait partout ya pensé
qu'il était libre a découvert qu il y
avait un réseau parallèle vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'ils allaient directement
dans le bureau du premier ministre est
qu'il y avait pire que ça il y avait un
service dans l'omerta
qui était chargé de dispatcher tout
avant il suffisait pas d'avoir à vous
voyez bien on a tous vu on était tous
témoins on a tous vu les lis pourtant
appuyé sur un bouton a vu le type qui
disais allô oui et qui disait qu'il
était bidon
oui mais c'est après la france mais
c'est après qu'on a découvert quand même
que c'était bien pire parce qu'en
réalité le ceux qui recevaient été
espionnées de la même façon donc tout
était bouclé c'était tout était vicié
dans une histoire qui fait il fallait
tout arrêter j'ai rien à cacher c'est
pas grave mais c'est 60 et c'est ce que
j'ai dit non mais c'est 70 la première
vraie période de d'émancipation c'est
avec des groupes vous vous rendez vous
ça veut dire 80 ça veut dire quand même
que à ce moment là d' entre le moment où
il voulait les politiques avaient décidé
qu'ils auraient une coup cet effort de
libéralisation sont arrivés à tout pour
deuxième équipe qui est venue installer
tout ce qu'il fallait clandestinement
pour être sûr d'avoir le contrôle quand
ils allaient leur échapper puisque
l'idée était celle là c'est que tout
allait leur échapper dernier avoue qu'il
fallait youn est partout et le ca s'est
arrêtée l'enquète quand on vient de
découvrir que ça partait dans tous les
sens et notamment vers tous les bureaux
de province alors québec c'est une folie
c'est une folie absolue il y avait plus
de se faire brasser mais il suffisait
d'une crise suffisait de surveiller la
centrale de récupération qui serait ce
qui s'est passé donc ça c'est un tué
tout le tout le dispute à la volonté de
surveillance
mais c'est pour dire que cette presse a
quand même été un problème éternel et je
lui souhaite c'est donc c'est encore
vrai aujourd'hui
hop c'est que sauf que la technique la
tactique ne suis pas venu pour rien afin
de s'acquitter parce qu'on va alors il
nous reste quelques minutes hurd à la
sauce animations c'est un regroupement
alors je me suis de passage
oui copia quoique voit que c'est un
regroupement d'associations de saint
quentin en yvelines qui s'est constitué
à l'issue du dernier conseil de
développement comme vous le savez ici
est sans doute monsieur gildas
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales ont depuis je crois une
quinzaine d'années la possibilité de les
élus de rassembler un certain nombre de
citoyens une sorte de représentation
pour commenter les décisions et la vie
publique
c'est un organe consultatif et ce sont
les élus qui nous sommes soient des
experts soient des représentants car
j'ai participé c'est donc ainsi de 3 ans
j'ai participé au dernier cycle à la
demande du président de l'époque dans un
groupe culture ou la question était
posée de savoir si saint quentin en
yvelines qui est née il ya une
quarantaine d'années dc avait
véritablement construit un récit de
saint quentin en l'occurrence non
puisque tout le monde s'est battu pour
faire exister sa commune et où son
mandat c'est comme dans une sorte de
paradigme qui est pas un problème de
personne mais qu'un problème de système
tout le monde se sacrifient à voile à
l'efficacité c'est pas une nouveauté et
pour elle pour faire vite c'est cette
idée comment donner l'âme de la ville
la question de son rayonnement et où une
ville rayonne appartements les gens sont
vives bien sont heureux et envoie depuis
chez eux
cette sorte de bien vivre et ses
animations c'est parti sur l'idée que
sans se substituer aux missions de la
collectivité territoriale est important
que les associations deviennent une
force d'action une force de proposition
et trouve les modalités qu'on n'a pas
encore établi jusqu'à maintenant pour
pouvoir
comment dirais-je construire participé à
mener un contenu au récit local de
manière très active
animation s'aiguise depuis deux ans
s'est manifestée par un premier festival
d'étudiants il ya peu est toujours en
train de cette-eygun le 6 octobre sont
invités les associations à venir prendre
connaissance de l'état d'avancement du
projet et puis surtout de venir parce
que finalement c'est un endroit on va se
remettre à penser la ville nous en tant
qu'habitant serait approprié pourquoi
pas rêver encore un petit peu
voilà un merci beaucoup il a saisi pour
des masses évoquons florence mercan et
jean baptiste suzuka merci beaucoup
philippe gildas et vous voulez quand
vous voulez merci vous qu stéphane
rousseau et jean charles lajoie dis à
bientôt pour un nouveau pas
[Musique]